salut dans la série mentale tips ou je
vous débloque une compétence dans votre
cerveau à la fin de cette vidéo à la fin
de la vidéo vous savez faire quelque
chose de nouveau on va parler des rêves
lucides et comme ça vous allez apprendre
à faire un rêve lucide peut-être même ce
soir cette vidéo est sponsorisé est
approuvée par exprès vpn avait peine
vous savez ce que c'est si vous ne savez
pas renseignez vous je plaisante
si vous savez pas ça vous permet de vous
connecter en faisant croire que vous
n'êtes pas à l'endroit où vous êtes
en gros c'est comme il ya un pont et
puis toi en fait t'es là et tout le
reste du monde croit que tu es là parce
que tu es connecter à partir de là voilà
mais utiliser les services express vpn
ça peut vous servir à quoi concrètement
imaginons moi qui suis beaucoup en
tournée je suis souvent dans les gares
dans les aéroports dans les hôtels dans
des wifi public
eh bien ça me permet de me connecter à
partir de mon vpn pour sécuriser ma
connexion qui dit tournée dit aussi
voyage donc quand je suis à l'étranger
qu'oscar thaïlande ou si je vais en
chine par exemple c'est intéressant
d'avoir un vpn pour se connecter à tous
ses services habituels que l'on a en
france mais vous pouvez aussi vous
connecter en faisant croire que vous
êtes en allemagne par exemple
démonstration pour le moment je suis
connecté à l'express de vpn depuis paris
mais maintenant là d'un coup de baguette
magique la germany car c'est bon je suis
je suis à francfort actuellement vous ne
saviez pas que j'étais à fond ça permet
aussi pour certains catalogues de
streaming comme netflix deux se
connecter pour avoir accès au catalogue
des autres pays
alors ça fonctionne dans la plupart des
cas pas tout temps je peux pas vous dire
que ça fonctionne à 100%
il utilise trust serveurs technologies
et ça ça compte pour moi qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'il est
impossible pour leurs serveurs de bn de
sauvegarder les datas de leurs clients
et ça a été auditée par pwc
j'apprécie particulièrement vous avez
toutes les infos dans la description il
ya 3 mois offerts pour vous en passant
par mon lien donc n'hésitez pas le lien
il s'affiche également ici merci express
vpn alors j'avais déjà fait deux vidéos
sur les rêves lucides mais le sujet mais
avec les vraiment une troisième vidéo
une petite mise à jour et puis dans
l'absolu vous me suivez pas tous en 2016
quoi tu vois tu commences à me suivre
quand d'ailleurs vrai abonnement abonnés
à la chaîne c'est pas abonnés à la
chaîne à ma propre chaîne loïc
génériques
[Musique]
où
comme toujours dans cette série l'idée
c'est de vous débloquez des compétences
dans le cerveau une fois que vous avez
regardé cette vidéo sentier des travaux
à faire ou des choses a répété à un
milliard de fois pour ce qui est de
qu'est-ce qu'un rêve lucide ou les
pièges de rêve lucide je vous laisse
vous référer aux deux autres vidéos que
j'avais fait précédemment vous pouvez
les regarder à la suite de celle là je
les mettrai en fin de vidéo dans la
description mais en gros faire un rêve
lucide c'est avoir conscience que l'on
rêve pendant le rêve c'est à dire
pendant qu'on est endormi on a
conscience qu'on est à l'intérieur d'un
rêve
et depuis quelques années il ya des
chercheurs qui cherchent pas ce que
c'est vraiment le talent des chercheurs
comment on pourrait provoquer le rêve
lucide
alors il ya une étude qui a été faite en
2014 qui a démontré qu'avec des
stimulations électriques qu'on envoyait
directement comme ça dans le cerveau des
gens et bien 77% des dormeurs avait des
éclairs de lucidité quand il recevait
comme ça de l'électricité pendant le
sommeil paradoxal
heureusement les rêves lucides n'ont pas
besoin de chimie ou de chocs électriques
transcrânien pour être provoqué on peut
le faire naturellement
merci et on le fait depuis longtemps
très longtemps très très très longtemps
tellement longtemps qu'on trouve même
des traces dans des tribus en amazonie
ou ailleurs je veux pas dire de bêtises
de gens qui pratiquent le rêve lucide
comme un art de vivre
la première chose qui aide à voir de la
lucidité onirique on appelle ça comme ça
c'est de faire une immersion dans le
sujet de s'imprégner à fond du sujet et
de donner là dessus de cet univers-là et
c'est pas mal parce que c'est exactement
ce que vous êtes en train de faire avec
cette vidéo
et ça ça va aider à provoquer des rêves
lucides chez vous pourquoi parce que la
nuit quand on dort il ya notre cerveau
qui traite un petit peu toutes les
informations qu'il a vécu dans la
journée et donc comme ce sera prêt dans
votre mémoire le cerveau et
l'inconscient fera plus facilement un
rebond là dessus mais commence à
imprégner donc en regardant cette vidéo
en regardant les deux autres ou
peut-être même ce soir avant de vous
coucher en regardant le film inception
qui traitent de sujets à quoi qu'il en
soit le déblocage a déjà commencé
l'intérêt darragh lucide c'est le
contrôle et donc ce qu'on peut
expérimenter dans cet univers imaginaire
grâce à ce contrôle mais ce contrôle il
y très nuancier d'areva l'aude c'est à
dire qu'on peut avoir le contrôle absolu
en clair on est dieu on peut changer les
décors on peut changer les lois de la
physique on peut s'envoler on peut on
peut changer les gens on peut faire
faire les
les actions qu'on veut aux gens qui a
autour de nous ça c'est assez rare c'est
vraiment le full contrôle c'est la plus
haute des nuances et la plus faible des
nuances qui est d'ailleurs souvent la
plus courante ont subi un scénario c'est
à dire que on n'a pas décidé des décors
de ce qui se passe exactement de
l'intriguent de l'action parce que dans
le dans le rêve il ya toujours un
conflit qu'on est en train de résoudre
quel qu'il soit donc on n'a pas de
décider de sa et par contre on a
conscience des dans un rêve et on a
notre liberté de penser et de mouvement
dans ce rêve où on agit avec ça au mieux
ce que vous devez savoir et comprendre
là on n'est pas dormir la vidéo pour que
ça continue de débloquer ces trois
choses la première chose c'est qu'un
rêve lucide ça dure pas forcément
longtemps et que le contrôle qu'on a de
suez pas forcément permanent
c'est à dire on peut très bien passer
d'une phase de rêve un rêve lucide avec
tous les pouvoirs
puis tout de suite après un rêve lucide
avec pas de pouvoir scénario imposé
puis après un rêve normal puis art rêve
lucide ça c'est très rare gros en
général un rêve lucide et entouré de
deux rêves normes austère à la fin d'un
rêve lucide on repart dans un rêve
normal et on perd la lucidité mais vous
voyez n'y a pas de règle vis-à-vis de ce
à quoi des fois quand on parle avec
quelqu'un qui a jamais fait un rêve
lucide il fantasme sur le fait que ce
soit un rêve de dengue et qu'on a tous
les pouvoirs toujours dedans c'est pas
si simple ça m'amène au point 2 un rêve
lucide c'est pas forcément un rêve de
ouf c'est toujours une expérience
incroyable la bible le fait d'être
lucide pendant un rêve
ça c'est dingue mais le raid en lui-même
n'est pas forcément dang surtout quand
c'est un scénario imposé par notre
inconscient il ya des rêves qui sont
plus marquant que d'autres pour plein de
raisons par rapport à ce qui s'y passe
l'autre jour je rêvais que je pilote un
avion forcément leur rêve ils étaient un
petit peu fou tu vois c'est pas parce
qu'on fait un rêve du site que c'est un
rêve qui sera incroyable a raconté pas
nécessairement parking c'est chouette
aviv et la troisième chose qui va le
plus nous intéressait là c'est qu'on
peut oublier un rêve lucide il ya une
idée reçue qui dit qu'un rêve du cid on
va s'en rappeler parce qu on était
conscient pendant le rêve non pas du
tout pas nécessairement qui subit le
même traitement que les rêves
ça veut dire qu'à votre réveil vous
pouvez oublier d'avoir fait un rêve
lucide ou avoir le vague souvenir
d'avoir fait un rébus il est de plus
vous en souvenir du tout après il suffit
parfois que vous ayez eu un réveil un
vrai réveil durant la nuit
vous rendormir pour que le lendemain se
souvenir du rêve lucide il soit
complètement effacée et c'est bien ça le
problème
on rêve tous et toutes chaque nuit même
toit qui peut-être pense ne pas rêver tu
rêves
sauf problème particulier on rêve tous
la nuit sauf que c'est difficile de se
souvenir de ses rêves encore plus à
l'époque à laquelle on vit où on a des
réveils on travaille plus naturellement
on se réveille en mettant à réveiller le
matin souvent en un très mauvais réflexe
la peine on se réveille et on prend le
téléphone dans les mains et on passe à
autre chose et le cerveau il est fait
pour évacuer le rêve de la vie il est
fait pour effectuer ce souvenir là pour
pas qu'on le confonde avec la réalité ou
pour pas que plus tard on confondent le
souvenir du rêve avec le souvenir de
quelque chose qui se soit déjà passé il
faut donc que vous tombiez votre mémoire
onirique et là aussi vous avez beaucoup
de chance c'est extrêmement simple à
faire en gros il ya trois choses
pourquoi parce qu'après il ya toujours
trois choses la première choses allaient
aller simple claire et logique elle va
vous changer la vie d'une manière
générale ne vous jetez pas sur votre
téléphone quand vous vous réveillez ses
mauvaises habitudes
il faut s'en débarrasser moi je lui
aussi pendant un temps je m'en suis
débarrassé ya quelques années quand vous
vous réveillez retrouvez vous vous même
prenez le temps de vous réveiller de
pensée de vous lever de prendre votre
petit déjeuner de vous laver et ensuite
seulement vous prendrez votre téléphone
donc n'allait pas directement capté de
nouvelles informations parce que ça va
encore plus vous déconnecter de noël en
deux du coup comme quand vous vous
réveillez vous jetez plus sur le
téléphone est bien gardé un petit peu
les yeux fermés et essayez de vous
rappeler un peu mieux de vos rêves parce
qu'ils sont encore présents ils sont pas
prêts loin en fait donc vous pouvez
retirer un peu comme le fils d'une
pelote de laine vous avez un petit
souvenir à temps je rêvais ça c'était
quoi et vous tirez là dessus mentalement
et vous allez retrouver un peu
l'intégralité du rêve donc refaite vous
un petit peu le rêve et un maximum
d'informations alors sachez que les
règles sont incohérents ils sont
décousus ça passe d'une scène à l'autre
ça n'a aucun rapport mais quand on est
dans le rêve ça nous paraît logique donc
quand vous allez chercher à bien vous
rappelez de votre rêve évidemment ça
donne une histoire déconstruite mais
c'est pas grave
rappelez-vous des différentes scènes que
vous avez un petit peu en flash et vous
allez essayer de vous les remémorer
comme ça ce qui nous amène à la
troisième chose
une fois que vous avez ses souvenirs en
tête vous noté ça dans un carnet
ou exceptionnellement dans l'application
de téléphone de votre choix dans
l'application de votre choix dans votre
téléphone de votre choix aussi parce que
sinon on n'a pas osé un matin on want
qu'est ce que c'est abitbol une fabrique
de quoi j'ai des pâtes contre vannes
mais vraiment noté le alors le plusieurs
jeux la faire moi c'est ce que je
faisais aussi quand j'essayais de
dompter ma mémoire onirique c'est
d'avoir un carnet et un stylo juste à
côté du lit ça vous réveillez vous noté
alors au départ moi je notais quelques
mots en disant comme ça ça me rappellera
le rêve
que nenni notez bien des phrases
entières parce que le temps passe et se
souvenir des sens plus profond de votre
mémoire donc ayez des phrases entières
décrivait le décor les sensations que
vous aviez le ce genre de choses on est
déjà la troisième partie de cette vidéo
donc à la troisième étape du déblocage
qui va faire que vous allez faire un
rêve lucide prochainement peut-être même
ce soir pour ce déclenchement il nous
faut exactement trois choses je suppose
puisque avec toi c'est toujours il faut
trois choses pour déclencher alors il
faudrait que c'est effectivement trois
choses
laissez pas qu'avec moi loïc dans la vie
d'une manière générale souvent il faut
trois choses
enfin malgré trois choses qu'il faut
dans la vie comme ça riri fifi loulou il
faut voir manger et dormir ou ou boire
manger dormir et respirer pour vivre et
pour être heureux il faut avoir une vie
personnelle épanouie une vie
professionnelle épanouie et des quoi ça
veut dire vous allez devoir grave et le
message dans votre inconscient
le message que vous voulez faire un rêve
lucide ça va vous aider en fait à
prendre conscience que vous rêvez quand
vous êtes en train de caler en gros
avant de vous coucher ce soir quand vous
sentez que vous vous endormez donc non
vous êtes déjà couché mais juste avant
de vous endormir vous dites en
chuchotant une phrase du type la
prochaine fois que je vais rêver j'en ai
conscience que je rêve
voilà vous allez prononcer une phrase
comme ça parce que ça envoie quelque
chose de très clair à votre cerveau que
vous êtes dans cette démarche là et ça
laisse une trace très forte alors il ya
une nouvelle technique qui est apparue
ces dernières années n'est pas bête du
tout c'est que si vous avez votre réveil
matin qui est mis à 8
heure par exemple alors vous mettez le
réveil un peu plus d'une heure avant 7h
ou 6h50 enfin vous garder l'autre réveil
également vous en rajoutez un 1h10 avant
et quand le réveil sonne vous l'éteignez
vous n'ouvrez pas les yeux vous dit la
phrase vouloir prononcer la prochaine
fois que je vais rêver je veux avoir
conscience que je rêve et vous allez
vous rendormir tout de suite beaucoup
plus instantanément que le soir avant de
vous coucher et ça va favoriser encore
une fois la lucidité en deux vous allez
devoir enclencher un test de réalité
alors ça c'est hyper important
c'est à dire que quand vous dormez votre
esprit critique
il dort complètement lui aussi est allé
les rêves c'est n'importe quoi vous êtes
dans un avion vous ouvrez une porte vous
êtes dans votre cuisine en train de
faire des pâtés et vous parlez à
quelqu'un et cette personne change de
visage
puis elle change de nom et ça change de
lieu est vraiment tout est normal cette
arrivée des trucs comme ça ou pas le oui
ok ok si vous avez un test de réalité
que vous faites régulièrement dans la
vie normale dans la réalité est
évidemment ça va devenir un petit pas un
toc une habitude que vous allez
reproduire malgré vous durant vos rêves
sauf que durant le rêve ces tests de
réalité ne va pas fonctionner et là vous
allez en avoir conscience que vous êtes
en train de rêver certaine excitation un
peu particulière un livre on va en
reparler après alors d'habitude chacun
sont propres tests de réalité mais là
comme le concept de la vidéo c'est vous
débloquez une compétence maintenant on
va avoir le même test de réalité
ensemble maintenant fait jeu s'il vous
plaît faites même temps loïc tu peux
essayer de le faire bien sûr ils avaient
tous passé votre nez mettre la main
devant notre bouche et vous essayez de
respirer non non non sans ouvrir la
bouche et sans dépasser le nez est-ce
que tu arrives à respirer loïc est ce
que vous allez arriver à respirer non la
réponse est non respirer maintenant
respirer vite donc vous n'arrivez pas à
respirer donc le test de réalité c'est
vrai on passe son lait et on voit si on
arrive à respirer
la réponse est non sauf que quand vous
allez essayer de faire ça par
automatisme dans un rêve
vous allez réussir à respirer car la
réactiver un peu votre esprit critique
qui va se dire waouh il se passe quelque
chose je crois que je suis dans un raid
et enfin de la troisième chose c'est
quand vous êtes dans votre lit le soir
et que vous imaginez un peu des
scénarios des choses comme ça vous êtes
en train de rêvasser comme on y essayer
de vous forcer à vous voir vous
à la première personne c'est à dire que
vraiment si vous rêvez de vous même si
vous rêvez de vous même du moins avant
de vous endormir vraiment imaginer les
yeux fermés que vous voyez vos bras
devant vous que vous voyez pourquoi pas
le flou de l'arête du nez qu'on voit ici
ici habituez vous à ça parce que quand
on rêve et qu'on veut faire un rêve
lucide le rêve lucide ne fonctionne pas
à ma connaissance quand on rêve comme
s'il y avait un on avait un regard
caméra et on se voyait en fait à la
troisième personne
on se voyait des portes et moi
malheureusement je rêve souvent comme ça
ce qui m'empêche parfois de faire des
rêves lucides donc il faut s'habituer à
s'imaginer soi même dans son propre
corps voyant par son propre regard
tu rêves comment toi là de la troisième
personne plus tôt ou avec tes yeux
la deuxième la deuxième personne c'est
quelqu'un d'autre type qui rêve pour toi
d'ailleurs je vous disais tout à l'heure
la première fois qu'on fait un rêve
lucide eux mêmes souvent les autres fois
au moment où l'on perçoit qu'on est en
train de faire un règle side où on a une
excitation le coeur qui s'accélère et on
peut se réveiller à cause de ça il ya un
truc qui marche pas mal c'est de se
créer un personnage fictif une espèce de
projection mentale qui apparaît dans ces
moments là alors là pour la faire
exister cette projection c'est très
simple vous fermez les yeux dans votre
reer mon neveu ou couchée et vous
imaginez en fait ce qui pourrait se
passer qui pourrait être cette personne
ce qu'elle pourrait vous dire qu'elle me
touati
dans ses rêves lucides comme si vous
pensiez un ami imaginaire ou un truc
comme ça
imaginez ces personnes-là fantasmer la
peau de fantasmes chelou parce que
j'avais vous dire vous pouvez imaginer
que c'est moi mais vraiment vous pouvez
créer un avatar de moi mr une projection
mentale et vous dire ben tiens quand je
serai un rêve du site qui serait bien
c'est sais que ça va me rappeler la
vidéo de fabien et que fabien arrive
vers moi en disant attend calme-toi tout
va bien c'est un rêve lucide tu es dans
ton rêve tu fais ce que tu veux
même le fait de vous expliquer ça là
maintenant ça va favoriser la création
de cette projection mentale et de cet
avatar est peut-être vous allez du coup
me voir apparaître sur un rêve lucide
si c'est le cas vraiment vous me dites
dans les commentaires ce sera assez cool
d'avoir vos retours là dessus parce que
oui voilà vous êtes enfin prêt à faire
votre premier rêve lucide ou peut-être à
refaire un rêve lucide cette nuit ou
dans celles qui viennent si c'est le cas
vraiment vous venez vous dites ça dans
les commentaires vous partagez votre
expérience racontez-nous le rêve c'est
très cool de créer un espace comme ça
petit récap des points essentiels pour
bien débloquer cette compétence vous
imprégner un maximum des rêves lucides
donc
et ma vidéo où les anciennes regarder le
film inception par les rêves lucides
avec des gens que vous connaissez donc
voilà s'imprégna max de sa deuxième
chose faire des tests de réalité assez
souvent dans votre vie normale
tenez ça continue à faire ça de jour en
jour troisième chose noté vos rêves
quand vous vous réveillez c'est très
important de faire ça et là quatrième
tout aussi important de formuler la
phrase avant de vous endormir que trois
choses mais là j'ai pas dis 4g juste
énuméré sega trois choses qui me
manquent et pour pas vous créer
d'impatience sachez qu'un bon rêveur
lucide comme on dit quelqu'un qui est
habitué à en faire il en fait rarement
plus de 5 par mois
donc ne soyez pas déçus de ne pas en
faire un chacun je pirate moi même ma
propre vidéo juste pour remercier avant
la fin express v n va parce qu'on ne se
brise et cette vidéo je vous rappelle
que 6 des peines vous intéresse vous
avez un lien dans la description qui
vous explique comment avoir les 3 mois
gratuits dès le départ voilà merci m
voilà à nouveau savoir de télécharger
dans votre cerveau une nouvelle
compétence de débloquer je vous
recommande d'enchaîner avec cette vidéo
qui était la première sur les rêves
lucides ou celle ci où je parle des
pièges sur les rêves lucides
si vous débarquez je m'appelle fabien
olicard abonnez vous à cette chaîne
youtube c'est gratuit activer la coche
pour ne pas rater la prochaine vidéo qui
va vous intéresser j'en suis sûr et moi
je vous dis à très vite ici ou sur mon
instagram
à très bientôt ciao